Felix: All right, Ken has been begging me for months to play with him and finally. It's your lucky day ken.
Kenneth: Oh my god, take me back.
Seán: *arghuhuhuh*
Ken: Take me back
Seán: The nipples look like the top of baby bottles
Felix: M'my god.
-That's so sexual Jack.
-All right! It's my time- my time to shine.
-HERE WE GO everybody you like my ah-
Kenneth: Look at that face-
-Felix: TWO, ONE, Look at that!
I didn't realise what you drew.
ooooooOOO that's a SEXY pose.
Pointing for the stars
F: Dude your shoulder your back muscles Ken my god
Yeaheheheh-- YEAH
Ah! Your face!
Ah no!
(oh YES)
F: That's my face come on
oh yeah
F: Come on. Oh oh Ken
OooohhoooooOOOOOoo
F: O MaH gAh
Let's have a look it's a Jackie boy
ooohh my God
oh mYGODhahah
What is that?
This game is fucking impossible!
F: Jack if you could not swear that would be great
THANKYOU
Stick!Stick!
Theres enough of you there!
hahaha
I like your sun tanning, it looks great.
Thank you!
I- I'm an older gent.
Yup.
NiiiIIIICe
F: Oh wow, oh hello boys. Here I cum ( ͡◉ ͜ʖ ͡◉)
Your back looks like an ass!
F: Because it is :-)
S: I'll call you backass from now on.
WOOOAHH
F: Oh and he cli- N0 n0 nO no, NONONO x2
F: Don't worry, I still got time.
S: Sh✞t. You still got 20 seconds, dammit
F: Are you telling me I have 15? I have 15 seconds of fun?? >:3
oohhoh
ohohohoho
oho
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
F: Oh, shit. I actually-
No no!NO NO!
hahhh!
ohhhhh
ohhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhh
OH! You still have 37 seconds!
F: I'm fine. I'm fine. I'm fine
S: You have half a minute.
F: I have half a minute...
S: GET UP THERE
F: Ayy I did it!!!
F: Oh you have a reserve, okay. That's why.
F: Ayy, what are you doing to your face, Ken?
F: Oh, hey there Ken how you doin'?
S: Oh my god, How do you do that?
F: Are you flexing, Ken? Are you flexing for the video? Ridiculous.
S: Oh, look at thiiiis. LOOK AT THIS
(RIP HEADPHONE USERS x1000)
S: ʏᴏᴜ'ᴠᴇ ɴᴇᴠᴇʀ sᴇᴇɴ sᴏᴍᴇᴏɴᴇ ᴄʟɪᴍʙ ᴍᴇɴ sᴏ ꜰᴀsᴛ.
F: OMG. Changing the game
F: YOU CALL THAT CLIMBING??
F: DIS IS-
F: oh. demmit.
xd
F: How do you guys do it? Seriously...
F: Yeah... Viking power.
*zero deaths*
F: I still have twenty- I still-
K: You're seriously low.
F: I- Shut your-
F: What, you got a problem with goats now?
F: Come ON
S W E D E N (is my city)
lol u got it wo
F: Look at that!
F: Nah no, there's no delay...
K: Do it, Grant!
F: Oh, you're a new person each time.
K: My run is ruined, reset!1
F: Finally a game with a video game character I can relate to
F: Jesus Ken, what are you doing?
Oh? He's entering the reserve!1 OH NO /s
F: O H N O K E N D:
F: You best climb faster there, boy
(please diy the conversation it's too much for translator-chan)
F: Wow, congratulations to Ken!!
K: Thanks everybody, I tried my best.
S: I want to put on a master class, are you ready?
F: The master class with Jacksepticeye?
F: How to climb, Jacksepticeye part one.
S: Look at this sh✞t, look at me go.
F: Come on. Hey, you got me right- right where I want it.
F: You tiny little boys, I bet you don't even drink protein every single minute.
F: I'll show you how it's done. I inhale protein. I am protein
✞✞✞✞✞✞✞✞✞✞✞✞✞✞✞✞✞✞✞✞
F: You gotta- you gotta get some suspension for the-
F: S H ✞ T
F: das right.
F: Come on, please!
Two seconds, ahhh?
Represent your country. I give up. You know what guys I'm out of here Peter's face. Don't give up. It's solid ass, whatever...
I don't care...
Yeah
There you go go can go can use those pink nips
I don't want to be that guy, Ken,
But it seems like there's a bit of a hue would dis match between your face and your body and nipples of course whoa
Don't make fun of my whiteness. I'm so sorry. Are you holding a nip?
Going outward
This is extreme titty fall, that's pretty good
Okay, here we go here we go. Oh damn
Better with controls god damnit
Whoa those mad foot here we go a fucking camera come on check, please
Come on, baby. There. You go grab that try oh good. No. I want to go higher enter the reserve
Is in the reserve everybody.
Come on kid leave that podium.
You don't got it Ken make that goats crowd can.
Booze buy your own team come on you can still do it Ken you can still do it add some epic music you got this
Can I'm so disappointed
But that's a dicker, I just I just can't do this come on touch me just gay. I'm
Giving up wow
I can't believe you fallen to the homophobes
Jackspedicy is the winner I'm so disappointed Burke Reed look what we made guys look what we made
I want someone I want fan out of this
I'm good. I'm good should we go back and change our face really quick? Yeah?
I'm almost done.
All right. Do you guys are going down this time
Pewds: Here we go!
Jack: Sweet Jesus
What's on your face?
(laughter) For fuck's sake
Pewds: What?
I just picked a random skin. I just picked a random one (yeah right)
Yeah, yeah oh
Pewds:Wow so pretty wow
Jack: Guys don't make fun of me, okay?
Ken: Majestic!
Pewds: That's right touch that symbol Jack
Jack: God
Like oh, you're the one worried about demonetization the most
and then you pick a Soviet fuckin symbol
Pewds: What are you talking about? I'm not the one culturally
APPROPRIATING
Like your teeth. I like that lip bite you got going on how I feel while playing this game the whole times like
Toast oh yeah come on Xavier we can do this oh
Yeah, oh yeah you guys been working out, no never you just like this
Wow you're
Very good ken you climb so good
Good can god you're so buff here. He comes ah
Are you like where should I put this ahead? Where should I put this hand?
Swedish massage everybody
Very good your
that's where the real protein goes
I'll show you guys the perfect male specimen okay
Okay, all right sure where is he don't see him anymore. He's coming. Don't you worry. There's no way he can be Irish at least
he's the goat
Come on come on baby come on baby for Ireland Sweden be on top oh
Are you kidding me, are you kidding all you need guys are pathetic. This is how you climb all right? Oh?
Yeah, show us green boy. Now look who's fucking green PewDiePie. Huh don't swear?
Oh
My god what the hell?
We're all here together
Beautiful we should just start going horizontal. No is this how fort notice I never played it. It's just like building it for you
That's what I think
You just build a but no oh
Pinky boy boys I
Thought that was fucking Michael from Vsauce on your face. Oh my god. It's climbing game
Or is it oh?
I
Want someone to get the verticality in their penis? What was that again Jake? That's the scientific term?
Felix okay, yeah dudes not the goats not like this
Fondling that God like a you guys are reacting to stuff. That's literally happened like ages ago
This is just a secret YouTube meeting. This is this is fake history porn here Joseph Stalin climbing the wall
We go here. We go. Yes. Got a good fucking system going now
This is too tall too intense
Damn it
My thigh boy Irish slinging
Fairy tale you weave you don't know you're calling me a weave for not knowing fucking
Words, you know what fairy tale episode 300. What's wrong with you?
Never getting a bit raises
It's that a new meme I never heard of that one you and your fucking memes
Deep swearing jack and see what happens Leon. How are you doing this? I'm gonna code. I'm gonna call YouTube on you boy
Oh my god. I got stuck on the dog the power of react on his side. It's the power of me being good at games
Which I am?
No, no no grab grab something 25% gaming channel PewDiePie here
Grab something grab something
shut your pie Paul you Irish slug of slime Irish silly I'm
family-friendly
Okay, it's up to us, Calvin Calvin Zaza there we go now. Oh no hate. Please something gets me everything so Dutch
Please don't do that
Please don't do that to the view the coat has representation you guys fucking paints 3d match your friends
I'm fucking 40 right now Jack. I need you to seriously tone down. This way you recorded a video with an Irishman
I'm gonna have to tell you
This is what happens this is what happened the shade of your skin is hurting my eyes your voice is hurting my eyes
That's extremely insensitive Jack. I can't believe you said that sorry. I'm insensitive to pink people look
Yeah, well maybe next time you'll think about pink people's feelings
Oh
Come on
It's time it's time young
Power levels
This is the video on YouTube right now
You got one second oh
My god. I don't even have the time in my time to get up. Oh god. Okay. Here. We go. It's all my god
You've never seen
Can't do it. No you
You Irish dumb ball go back in your example slimy scum
Hey you take that back right now ah
Come on come on
Come on can show what you got second choice Carrie - oh no America is gonna
You like that you DeeDee teeing that goat?
Tioga baby, this is how you do it oh?
You look at though he looks good well, we have to give it to the meatball
Wow wow what a tower all right? I look forward to see your tweet boys